[Music]
all right people it's friday which means
it's time for another round table
extravaganza sorry for the minute or two
delay there the internet goblins were
eating the wires apparently i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report and
joining me today
is the ceo of prageru marissa streit the
president of ralston college dr stephen
blackwood and the best-selling author of
the end of gender doctor dr debra so
marissa stephen deborah welcome to the
reuben report
hi dave
all right good to have you guys uh
marissa you are long overdue for being
on this show deborah you are an old
reuben report veteran and steven glad to
have you on for the first time uh we're
gonna be talking all about uh
the the fight for education the fight
for our kids the fight for sanity uh
we're gonna talk about what's going on
at the universities uh in the elementary
schools and junior highs we're going to
talk about how the administration is
dealing with this the battle in the in
the culture war with disney and gender
and everything else uh and uh i wanted
to get away sort of from the straight up
politics and economy and uh no we are
not talking about january 6 today that
will be the one time on this show i
think that i mentioned january 6. uh
real quick before we get to any of that
let me talk to you guys about policy
genius and then we'll get going let's
face it guys shopping for life insurance
is no fun at all all that hunting down
quotes and keeping track of who's who it
can be a real pain in the butt but if
you've got
people who depend on you children
parents or even business partners it's
incredibly important policy genius is
your one stop shop to find the insurance
you need at the right price and you can
head over to policy genius dot com slash
ruben to get started in minutes you'll
be able to compare personalized quotes
from top companies to find your lowest
price you could save 50 percent or more
on life insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius policy genius doesn't
add extra fees doesn't sell your info to
third parties and they have thousands of
five star reviews
across google and trustpilot they have
options that offer coverage in as little
as a week and let you avoid unnecessary
medical exams since 2014 policy genius
has helped over 30 million people shop
for insurance and has placed over 150
billion in coverage policy genius works
for you not the insurance companies so
get started today head over to
policygenius.com
ruben to get your free life insurance
quote and see how much you could save
and now back to me all right here we go
so
everyone watching this show
knows that we have a problem with
wokeness everyone knows that it's in it
has infected virtually all of our
cultural institutions our political
institutions
but today we're focusing on our
educational institutions and i want to
focus on what's going on over in my what
once was my hometown state of new york
we've got some info here from the daily
wire
new york democrat governor kathy hoschel
announced on wednesday that all 64 suny
college campuses are being directed to
update their policies to ensure that a
person's chosen gender identity and
pronouns are used
the policy will include chosen names to
appear on diplomas and campus profiles
along with the ability to select x as a
gender option by the fall 2023 semester
every person regardless of their gender
identity or the name they chose to go by
deserves to have identity documentation
that reflects who they are ho chill said
in a statement the statement
specifically noted that the student's
chosen name and pronouns will appear in
campus portals class rosters and student
email addresses
among other changes uh stephen i want to
start with you on this one uh i went to
a suny school i went to suny binghamton
it was one of if not the best suny
school at the time i don't know sort of
where it ranks in that right now uh but
this is pretty consistent with
everything coming out of new york
everything going across our
quote-unquote higher education uh right
now what do you make of this
well i mean i think it's pretty easy to
see that there is
obviously a certain kind of contemporary
prejudice and ideology behind
this kind of thing
but i do think it's pretty important
also to drill down to the level of
principle here
when there's a lot of coercion and
bullying into saying certain things
i think in this case we have to
acknowledge dave that this is merely
individuals stating their own
preferences now we may think that those
individuals may be influenced by a
very
anti-scientific ideology that is
destabilizing one of the most
fundamental categories of of of human uh
beings the namely their their sex but we
should also remember that this is the
state university of new york it is uh it
is there for the people of new york the
governor is the elected head of the
state if the people don't like what she
is doing with their university they can
they can change it so i think that there
is a sense in which you could even
defend this as in the tradition of
american individual liberty however
misguided we may think what these people
are doing is uh no one's being forced
into anything you did not let me down
with a thoughtful answer as sort of
silly as we all may think it is yes
choice is there i kind of don't like it
coming from the state however
deborah i'm going to throw to you on
this one because they're also allowing
you to select x as a gender option now
it's one thing if you're saying okay i'm
going to call myself a different name or
i'm going to call myself another gender
x is not a gender is it am i missing
something deborah this is your
department
no i mean non-binary is not backed by
science whatsoever and so x would be i
guess for some people who want to be
special that's what they would have
designated on their driver's license or
passport or birth certificate now
so i agree in with stephen in terms of
individual liberty and i think people
should be free to identify however they
want even if it is a scientific
anti-scientific concept and i go into
more of the science behind why there are
two sexes and only two genders in the
end of gender but
you know when it's being recognized by
law this i find very worse and because
why are ideas that are anti-scientific
being put into policy we see this in
medical policy scientific organizations
have capitulated to it and i think it's
just going to make it more difficult for
these ideas to be removed from society
when they are being given legal
sanctions
marissa i don't want to stab you right
to start but you live in california
which is the uh
let's say the west coast new york so
this is the type of stuff that if it is
not in the cali higher ed system will
obviously be there what do you make of
this
um you know i think it's interesting
when you talk about freedom because if
it was a private school would be a
different issue right you pay a certain
amount of money you don't like it take
your kids out put them in a public
school and you know hopefully live with
that but i think when public schools are
doing things like this the option of
freedom is no longer really there if
you're a parent who can't afford a
private school and you can't homeschool
your child how are you really free to
choose uh not to mention i i understand
your point that one could then elect
different officials but if you think
about the spam of a life a child's life
the difference between kindergarten and
fourth grade those are four years of
having no option of making any sort of
change and this kind of idea that let's
you know vote with our feet or or pull
our kids out is not that simple for for
many parents it's the reality that you
do have to go to work and put your kids
in a school and can't wait four years
without them brainwashing your child and
essentially eroding the way they're
thinking stephen what do you make of
that point that we're all sort of agreed
on the on the civil liberty side and the
individual right side and the choice
side but that there's just this sort of
slow descent to hell with this thing
that will just keep bringing in ideas
that are wrong and then you know we can
we can defend someone's individual
choice but that the system itself and as
marissa's saying okay you can elect
other people but people have four year
or six year terms and you know your kid
once they've sort of been infected by
this at five it's sort of uh out of the
barn by
nine ten years old
oh listen you you won't find a more
strident defender of uh freedom of the
freedom of the mind or
opponent of
let's say propaganda and ideology then
than i am but i do want to say that this
is a very this is this is different
right i mean these are individual
stating preferences no one's being
forced into doing anything here and it
is not k-12 public school this is the
the state university system of new york
no one is forced to go there and when
they do they're not forced to say that
they're any other gender than they want
to say so i do think we have to you know
it's important if we're going to
criticize our our
opponents for being reductive and
ideological then it's important that we
ourselves show nuance in the this
analysis and in this case uh however
idiotic i may think uh virtue signaling
in the worst kind of way this uh the
governor may be being in this instance
uh it is categorically different than
what we see at the elementary school
level and you're actually forcing
children to learn things that are uh
dangerous and wrong so let's go to
another version of this that that takes
out the choice part because we're going
to go up to where you are right now
deborah in toronto i've got some more
info from the daily wire here george
brown college in toronto presented those
attending the zoom call this was a zoom
call amongst students and faculty to
read a lengthy statement to check a box
saying they agreed that they had
benefited from white privilege and would
commit to decolonization
the college fix reported the students
and faculty who click the i agree box
are acknowledging that they benefit from
the colonialization and genocide of the
indigenous peoples of this land and are
agreeing it is imperative we constantly
engage in acts of awareness and
decolonization the outlet noted deborah
not only are you in toronto but this
directly sort of hits this this
individual choice versus being sort of
coerced or forced into doing something
yeah well in canada i mean we see land
acknowledgments and this talk about
decolonization this is like the pet
racial project up here
and i do think it's important for us to
acknowledge history but i question what
do these types of initiatives actually
do to help indigenous people or the
indigenous community and you do see land
acknowledgments they're like pronouns
they show up in people's email
signatures they are all over university
websites people will say them at the
start of meetings and conferences
and now we see them at the start of zoom
calls and so going back to steven's
earlier point about um
you know the gender
ex designation people want to identify
as non-binary or say you say them
pronouns what happens then if someone
says hey i don't want to go along with
that or hey i don't want to check the
box in order to
be a part of this meeting does that mean
that they're not allowed to have an
education and that's where my worry is
because i think higher education
especially should be focused on
encouraging people who want to be there
to learn not necessarily be
indoctrinated by a particular ideology
yeah marissa what do you think about
that that there's sort of a social
pressure that goes along with this so
even in this case at george brown it
sounds like they had to do it uh but
regardless of whether they're fully
forcing them to do it or not fully
forcing them that there's a general
social pressure at all of these
institutions to say you are either trans
or non-binary or pansexual etc etc
i i think it's beyond a social pressure
first of all at that age social is
everything right i mean kids are so
focused on their social life but on top
of the social pressure i think that kids
are afraid they're afraid of faculty
they're afraid of what's going to go
in their grades and frankly they have
learned through the education system
throughout the years that winning victim
bingo gives them a stronger voice and so
many kids uh and uh and and college
students realize that if they are just a
white male christian they don't have as
much of a voice as somebody who wins
victim bingo and has all the other uh
points to them and so what we are seeing
is more and more kids are actually
trying to identify as one of those
categories so they also can't feel heard
and so they can then be affirmed as well
and that is what scares me is that
people in america are starting to try to
put themselves into victim boxes instead
of successful boxes
stephen since you've never been on the
show can you uh just take a moment and
tell people a little bit about what
you're doing at ralston college and i
know jordan peterson is involved so my
audience will definitely want to hear a
bit more and how you're how you're
combating some of this stuff
well it's pretty simple really we think
that the answer to the problems in
higher education is just to
found superior alternatives and not to
complain about what's wrong
as important as criticism is uh
you've got to build build a new and
ralston college endeavors to do that
it's both a reinvention and a revival of
the university we hope uh
at its best and uh so it's pretty it's a
pretty simple analysis if you don't like
what's going on try and do it more
better beautiful do it better more
beautifully more effectively and what we
see is that there is an enormous
appetite in young people for honest uh
serious
uh thinking and so we recently launched
our first degree program it's a master's
in humanities it's just a one-year
degree there's no tuition this year it's
entirely sponsored by philanthropy and
we've had a thousand applicants and it's
just it's
you know on the one hand it's it's
hugely encouraging for us and it's it's
it's such a
rewarding and beautiful thing to see
this interest on the other hand you've
got to say holy smokes what a mess it is
out there that a new college with no
track record merely holding out an
honest shingle saying here we are going
to give you the best that has been
thought and read and create a space for
you to think uh er with radical freedom
uh in the context of friendship and
uh the the pursuit of truth and that
sends a huge message
across the country
i always tell people to build new things
and the fact that you're doing it with
jordan peterson i think uh i think
you're gonna have far more than a
thousand applicants uh by the end of
today uh let's jump on to the next topic
though because you know we talked
obviously about this stuff at the
university level but it's happening in
elementary schools as well marissa we're
going to go to your uh hometown here we
got more from the daily wire parents in
beverly hills showed up to their local
school board meeting this month to
express their shock and disappointment
with what they said was the fifth grade
sex education curriculum in 2016
california health youth act added to the
existing state sex ed standards and
california began requiring any k-12 sex
ed to include instruction on gender
identity and sexual orientation because
sex ed is taught in fifth grade
ten-year-olds are exposed to those
topics unless their parents opt them out
sex ed in grades k through 6 must teach
about gender gender expression gender
identity and the harm of negative gender
stereotypes as well as affirmatively
recognize different sexual orientations
and be inclusive of same-sex
relationships and discussions and
examples according to an american civil
liberties union handout about the 2016
law another dad of two daughters
attending school in the district said
the fifth grade sex ed classes included
a lot of disturbing things including the
idea that gender is something that many
people think they understand but they
don't
debra you probably understand this more
than anybody else this is happening in
california state schools let's be clear
this is state schools uh you mentioned
there are only two genders you wrote a
book about it what is going on here and
what should these parents do
it's so crazy because these activists
they are very smart they're very sneaky
and they're always doing this behind
parents backs and i think it's very
telling especially what that one father
said about how
they talk about how gender is something
that people think they understand they
don't because that's a way for activists
to really get in there and cause people
who i mean it's not that difficult to
understand gender it's really not this
big complex thing that activists have
made it out to be but it causes people
to doubt themselves and so when they
think these ideas i'm hearing sound
pretty crazy but what do i know i'm i
guess i i guess i don't know i guess i
should defer to the experts and so then
people are being brainwashed into
thinking that what these so-called
experts have to say is actually
legitimate and it's if your audience has
not seen what is a woman i highly
recommend they go and watch it i was
very fortunate to get to be interviewed
by matt walsh for the documentary and to
see these so-called experts fall apart
over the most simple questions is i mean
that's that says everything so i would
say advice to parents is really just
trust your gut um
if it doesn't feel right to you and
especially if they're doing behind your
back you have every reason to be upset
by it and don't let them call don't let
them call you hateful make you feel
badly about it deborah you'll love this
a couple years ago i was in new york and
i was having dinner with an old friend
who's like pretty active in the trans
community he's not trans but he's pretty
active in the community we're debating
this stuff and all i i kept saying you
know i want anyone to live however they
want to live but that you can't deny
biology biological reality and he said
dave you don't understand quantum
physics
and i said i'm sure i don't but i'm
pretty sure you don't either and that's
the level of sort of the craziness like
it's just sort of one crazy on top of
another marissa okay we're talking about
beverly hills here you live close enough
to beverly hills uh i know you have
young kids you have had to move your
kids from school to school almost
everyone we knew in la was doing the
same thing because of all this nonsense
what do you do
you know i'm calling this the great
awakening because i had taught every
grade kindergarten through 7th here in
california i used to run a school myself
i have a master's in education like you
mentioned i have three children
and for years i've been talking about
the problems here and much of it was
an answer that i would got from would
get from other parents is that i'm
exaggerating i'm overreacting such sex
education is so important we need to
make sure that kids understand their
bodies and know how to protect them but
sadly sex education has evolved into
something totally woke as well as every
other department in uh in education
these days and so what do we do i mean
parents need to wake up we're already
seeing that they're waking up i think
some parents have the option of pulling
their kids out as i had when i heard
that my kindergarten class is now going
to have a transgender bathroom as well
as uh more kindergartners apparently
boys that identify as girls um which is
statistically impossible you can talk to
deb dr debra so a little bit more about
that
but here in los angeles i'll give you
another example my friend sends her kid
to a local high school where half of the
graduating class were boys and half of
the boys in the graduating class now
identify as women and wore dresses to
the prom i mean how is that even
possible but you're having this culture
that is pushing this idea that you are
confused about your gender and these
poor children i mean yes we need to give
them choice but when you're constantly
pushing this culture on them you're
pushing a choice that is not in their
best interest and so parents need to
wake up this is not a political issue
this is an issue that has to do with our
society and our children and it's really
existential and i think there are so
many many ways to get involved whether
it's send your kids to a better college
you don't need to send them to harvard
anymore you know send them to colleges
that actually believe in your values but
also inoculate your kids from an early
age talk to them prageru.com has now
prigger you kids you can have them watch
all our shows that help you know give
them a little bit of a brain boost and
really as deborah mentioned you need to
know what your kids are learning you
can't just send them to school and pick
them up give them a shower and put them
to bed we we all need to take more
responsibility over what is going into
our kids brains not just what's going
into their tummies let me just jump back
to deborah real quick before i throw
this even on on to marissa's point about
you know this sort of social contagion
part that so many kids okay this high
school in l.a half the boys are now
wearing dresses to the to the prom and
all of this kind of stuff um
do you have any numbers on sort of or or
research on how many of them actually
just it's it's a phase that's a
two-month operation or the second they
get out of the school or maybe they uh
move to another state or something that
this stuff just washes away
we don't have those data yet and i think
it would be really impossible next to
impossible to to
collect them objectively in today's
political climate because that would be
seen as inherently transphobic although
i just recently wrote about a poll that
came out showing that 5 of americans age
18 to 29 identifies transgender or
non-binary so five percent of people age
18 to 29 that's a lot and within that it
breaks down to
three percent who are non-binary two
percent who are transgender male or
transgender female so as marissa said i
think a lot of this comes down to
intersectional bingo in that people are
if especially if you are white and a man
how are you going to escape being called
an oppressor the best way to do that is
to pick a new gender identity and if
you're non-binary say or if you wear a
dress well you don't really have to do
anything other than wear that dress and
i mean
as i sit here i could tell you that i'm
non-binary and you'd have to call me
they them it's as simple as that
all right well let me throw it to the
oppressor on this panel then uh steven
as a white man uh you know your your
expertise obviously is higher ed as
we've been talking about this is this is
elementary school level but what would
you do if you were say a principal at
one of these schools uh or an
administrator superintendent et cetera
what what would you do if they were
pushing all of this stuff at your school
all right
on this i have a pretty clear view i
think that
that
there comes a point that it is simply a
uh is it immoral to
force children to engage with
uh this ideology uh and uh
so i i you know it's always easy to say
what you would do if you were in some
situation and of course the devil's
always in the details they want to see
very clearly what was being proposed but
fundamentally that's the kind of thing i
can see
absolutely going to uh
going to the stakeover and resigning my
position you know but i think there's
another point here too dave which is
that it's not just the ways in which and
we very rightly point out how how toxic
uh destabilizing uh these
and wrong-headed unscientific these
ideas are it's also
i mean have you checked in what students
actually learned by the time they get
through high school i mean i mean the
notion that we have kind of you know
weeks and months of a curriculum to
devote to uh this kind of pseudo uh
scientific ideological claptrap when you
know
students are not learning how to read
and write to a high level or the or the
three are the three are the reading
writing arithmetic it's absolutely
astounding when you look at what
students are not learning by the time
they get to the end of the 12th grade
that the notion that somehow our schools
should be filled with this kind of
social propaganda rather than focusing
fundamentally on what they're absolutely
exist to do which is to teach young
people what they need to know to live
fully human lives and that to me is the
real scandal here is the betrayal of
that responsibility yeah that to me is
the is the biggest part of this forget
what you think what any of us think
about gender identity or any of this
it's all of the stuff that they're then
not teaching them because they're
spending all the time on this uh you
know here in florida we've got this guy
ron desantis who's pretty good about
fighting all this stuff back and you
know the biden administration is now
threatening states that don't implement
this woke ideology and the gender stuff
in schools they are threatening with
holding back school lunches for kids
that need it believe it or not yes it's
true we've got some video
we're prepared for what biden throws our
way uh and you know yes part of it's the
inflation and the gas part of it are
intentionally destructive policies like
trying to deny
school lunch programs for states that
don't do transgender ideology and the
schools i mean give me a break totally
off his rocker to be doing that we're
fighting on that don't worry
can you imagine regardless of how you
feel about the gender ideology stuff
that you would punish kids i mean that's
what they're doing you would punish kids
through lunch
letting them be hungry because they're
not going woke with all of this stuff uh
marissa you're in cali again i keep
saying it i don't mean it yeah i don't
know defensively you keep reminding me
you know what this makes me think about
i used to say the teacher unions hate
their opponents more than they love
children and that's what it comes down
to
and uh you know that's why they keep
disappointing the children and the
families and yeah i see it in california
but by the way
the problem we have is this is not just
in california it's really all over the
country and if you ask yourself why a
big part of it is because most teachers
go through what i call left-wing
seminary
i have a master's in education most
people who go into trying to get a
master's in education will go through
this left-wing ceremony and uh seminary
and if they'll move to florida or
nashville or new york wherever they go
they'll take those ideas and ideologies
with them and
like mention like we mentioned before i
mean these ideas are immoral and these
ideas are not about really educating a
child most teachers actually are not
even taught how to teach math math and
literacy it's no surprise why close to
fifty percent of los angeles uh that
graduate from high school can't even
read or or write or let alone try to
solve any sort of complex math problem
and that it really stems from the fact
that we need to educate better educators
so that when they move around the united
states they're better equipped at
teaching our children and we need to
keep the standards so that people love
children more than they love politics
wouldn't that be refreshing uh well
going from ron desantis doing it right
here in florida let's throw to this clip
of joe biden and you're not going to
believe who he's blaming for the culture
war we're talking about
today there are too many politicians
trying to score political points trying
to
ban books
even math books i mean did you ever
think even your younger teachers you
ever think when you'd be teaching you're
going to be worrying about book burnings
and banning books
all because it doesn't fit somebody's
political agenda
american teachers
have dedicated their lives to teaching
our children lifting them up
we got to stop making the target of the
culture wars
that's where this is going
so what he's saying there basically is
that any of these
states that do anything about critical
race theory or the gender stuff that
they're banning books meaning they're
not letting anti-racist baby and the
rest of it in the curriculum uh we also
don't teach mind conf i'm pretty sure uh
deborah i assume you don't have a
problem and you're probably a little
jealous as a canadian that some states
can do some stuff on this right
well we're usually about six months
behind you guys so i have that to look
forward to but i really i really thought
this was like the pot calling the kettle
black and i think this is another way
that
this ideology is so insidious because it
makes parents who have understandable
concerns it makes them feel like they're
the crazy ones i mean if you go back to
your earlier example about lunches
i understand why most everyday people
don't want to go up against trans
activists because they are so powerful
and not only are they influencing all
this legal policy and medical and
scientific
initiatives but now they're also getting
to say who gets to be fed in terms of
underprivileged kids
that to me has what do bathrooms have to
do with the well-being of children i
mean it's totally crazy to me that if if
you have schools that say they're not in
favor of this ideology you're going to
starve the children
stephen i assume you're against starving
children
so i certainly am i'm also against the
federal government being able to hold
the purse strings over education i think
that
it's it's far from obvious to me there's
any constitutional
uh uh in the united states there's any
constitutional justification for the
department of education in fact one
thing needs to be said about canada it
doesn't have it does not have a federal
department of education that has led
actually to a greater diversity amongst
the provinces uh in what they can do and
here in the united states i think we
would do damn well to return education
to the places that it should be which is
fundamentally driven by the parents of
the children and the communities that
serve those children and if we had that
then the federal government wouldn't be
able to coerce us
of course coerce their ideology on
people by denying hungry children lunch
yeah and perhaps fund students instead
of systems something that uh chris ruffo
who i know you guys are all friends with
uh is really pushing right now all right
we got one more and it's the one that
really sort of blew this thing up over
the last say five or six months
uh into a cultural phenomenon and this
of course is everything happening over
at disney so chris ruffo who i just
mentioned who's been on the show many
times
he got this video we've shown this on
the show i think twice already uh an
internal
chat that they were having over at
disney this is disney executive producer
latoya ravenow uh and they were having a
whole thing on diversity and inclusion
and equity and how they spread messaging
within their movies etc etc take a look
my little pocket of like you know proud
family disney tva um
the showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda all that like momentum
that i felt like that
sense of i don't have to be afraid to
like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background like i was just
wherever i could just basically adding
queerness to like the if you see
anything queer in the show i'm proud of
them but like i just was like no one
would stop me and no one was trying to
stop me
all right so she's got her not so secret
gay agenda then one of the other
executives there was going on and on
about her gay kid and her pansexual
child and a whole bunch of other things
now i don't have a problem with gay
people i'm i'm actually married to a gay
guy so i'm i'm usually okay with gay
people um except when dinner's late uh
but this idea that they are telling you
what they are doing again and this is
with children this is with children and
there was a further video that came out
after this were disney ceo bob chappic
basically begging for forgiveness from
these people that he has not been a good
enough ally to all of these people uh
marissa you mentioned prageru kids
before i mean i'm at the sort of just
build new things and let disney burn
point are you there already
well i'm definitely there first of all
i'll say that i also have no problem
with gay people i happen to have a very
good uh
friend who's married to a gay guy
and so you know because i know they'll
just love to attack us because we just
say anything right um but it makes me
frankly sad i grew up with disney uh and
there is no baby better babysitter than
the television every once in a while
where i want to cook dinner or or take a
bath or relax or something but now i
can't trust uh disney anymore because i
don't know what kind of garbage is going
to go into my kids brains unless i watch
every second of it before i allow my my
kids to watch it and so a couple of
years ago that kind of anxiety as mama
bear has led me to really build another
enterprise here at prageru and that's
prageru kids because i know that all of
us as parents do want to be able to turn
on the television and allow our children
to watch something that we can trust and
that we know would nourish their brain
and not hurt their brains and so we did
launch prageru kids and we now make
edutainment for every single age
kindergarten all the way through
if you're 104 we have content for you as
well but really the goal here is so that
there is something that parents can
trust that is going to be good for them
that is going to be wholesome and like
what stephen is doing we can complain or
we can also take action and try to
provide some services to a very large
audience that is interested in an
alternative choice so that people can
vote have the option of voting with
their feet there is somewhere else to go
and so if you don't like what disney is
producing at the very least you now know
that you can download prageru kids and
have your children watch something that
is going to be good for them and that
you can trust so speaking of doing
something last week i went to the belly
of the beast myself i went to orlando
home of disney with scary ron desantis
and here's what happened all right so
first off we have to start with the
obvious one
gay
[Applause]
he didn't even flinch
nothing
stephen the stormtroopers did not burst
in they did not arrest me i said gay to
him he actually uh met my husband for
the second time right before that took a
picture with us they've given us baby
onesies um it's just
endless onslaught of nonsense huh
well i mean i think we we need to i mean
it it's the other one you put dye in the
water so you can see kind of like you
know where the water stream is going i
mean anyone can tell that these
ideological uh coercions are coming from
the university uh the university is
upstream of absolutely everything else
it's it's from there that you get the
teachers colleges that marissa was just
talking about policy politics culture
architecture art and so on it all starts
in what happens in the university and i
think we also need to be pretty frank i
mean conservatives can spare me the
outrage frankly you know william f
buckley wrote god manageale in 1951 that
71 years ago alan bloom closing the
american mind 1985 nearly 40 years ago i
mean if people who want to call
themselves conservatives in the small c
sense like we're looking to preserve the
best of what we've inherited had founded
new colleges and universities 30 40 50
even 20 years ago we'd be living in a
different country right now so it's
either put up or shut up in my opinion i
love it man that's the opportunity and
that's what you're doing so it's it's
absolutely perfect uh deborah i mean you
saw this of course years ago at the
research level too
so it's just
it's just absolutely everywhere and and
you changed your life because of it
right uh i won't be redundant cause i'm
sure your audience has heard me say this
a million times we did talk about this
the first time i was on your show but i
left academia because gender ideology
had gotten so insane and now i'm a
journalist and you know i really applaud
marissa and steven for what they're
doing because i think it is so important
to be fighting back against this and
i think the fastest way to put parents
off of trans rights and gay rights is to
force feed it to their children in
programming behind their backs and i
think they are totally insane to think
that parents are just going to roll over
and let activists take over their kids
minds
so i think it's fantastic what ronda
sans is doing and he's not he's not
backing down and i think we need more of
that
you guys were absolutely fantastic i
thank you deborah we're going to link to
your book marissa we are going to link
to prageru kids and stephen we are going
to link to ralston college i thank you
guys have a good weekend i'm going to
finish up without you for a couple
minutes but we'll definitely have you
all back so thank you very much
thanks dave thanks for having us
everybody
that is the week it is friday we're
going to be shutting it down here i hear
a rumor that you guys are going to
jurassic park this weekend is that is
that true someone told me oh phoenix
didn't know about it you're going to
i was told you guys are all going you
didn't invite phoenix what happened you
didn't want to go oh you don't want to
go to jurassic park oh you want to go to
downton abbey too with me is that right
okay phoenix and i are going to downton
abbey too michael and connor are going
to jurassic park i hope you will get off
the machines and go do something that
makes you happy and eat some good food
and listen to some good music and not be
crazy about the nonsensical hearings
that were happening last night i did not
pay one second of attention to any of it
it's all just drivel and it's trying to
keep your attention over here when your
attention should be over here uh if you
want to play along over the weekend join
me at
reubenreport.locals.com and of course
our full interview with ron desantis is
up over there and in case you forgot i
did add one show to the tour do we have
the image we don't have the image that's
all right
he started the weekend early look at you
you're not getting chick-fil-a today
we're having chick-fil-a after this
which uh
i'm gonna have to shut it down for the
rest of the day you i eat chick-fil-a we
do it once a month and the guys know
it's like we have to clear out dave's
schedule i have two of those chicken
sandwiches and then i'm just
i'm just laid out for the rest of the
day but it's worth it it's worth it uh
but i will be at the miami improv with a
surprise guest on july 14th you can go
to daverubin.com
events on that happy friday everybody
have a great weekend and we'll be back
on monday